what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
breaking down the latest epic events of
the black clover war are including the
unveiling of a brand new arcane tier
magical power the conclusion of the
fight between Austin and Dante at least
for now and the long-awaited return of
my favorite black clover character there
is a lot to talk about I am loving this
arc as I'm sure you can tell so let's
get into it if you enjoy the black
clover content right here on the channel
and you want us to keep it go and please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar please don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
clicking the bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you want to see
our videos the YouTube algorithm has
been changing again and a lot of people
have been missing videos so please be
aware of that by the way if you enjoyed
the visual aspects of these videos and
not just hearing my voice then you have
my editor Dakota broski to thank for
that
he's an ANA tuber as well just like
myself so please check him out link in
the description finally this video will
of course contain black clover manga
spoilers I'm talking about the very
latest information that we have so far
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned the latest chapter starts
right where the previous chapter left
off with Dante in disbelief that hasta
was able to actually scratch his face
Dante is so upset that he decides to
straight-up fistfight hasta which is a
pretty massive flex in and of itself and
we can assume that thanks to Dante is
gravity magic each one of his punches
has the weight of like a million in
normal human punches and so the
aggravator Dante and berserk hasta
continue to clash and the chapter then
shifts focused back to gauche who is
still out there slowly dying from a
massive wound in his torso gray is of
course still upset that she can't do
anything to help gauche and as she is
bawling her eyes out we get a flashback
to Gray's own tragic backstory it turns
out that Grey's character is closely
based on the famous fairy tale
Cinderella and when you think about the
whole transforming her
Kieran's thing it kind of makes sense
except we don't have a fairy godmother
at least not yet
this is definitely not the first time
that a characters backstory is basically
a retelling of a popular fairy tale as
we saw with Charlotte's backstory which
was extremely similar to Sleeping Beauty
before she joined the black bulls grey
lived with her stepmother and two
stepsisters the stepmother and
stepsisters mistreated gray they forced
her to spend all her time cleaning and
washing everything around the house and
because of this grey was always covered
in dirt and ash which is where the name
is Cinderella comes from the word
Cinderella is a reference to being
covered in ash or cinder-gray
stepsisters loved wearing fancy clothes
and makeup and they always mocked gray
for wearing raggedy clothes and for
being so dirty they called grey ugly and
told her that her appearance was
shameful which is part of the reason why
grey became so shy and self-conscious
from a very young age she was
traumatized by the fact that her
stepsisters constantly mocked her
appearance and this explains why grey
eventually started hiding her true
appearance from pretty much everyone by
using her transformation magic to always
look like someone else one day back when
she was still just learning
transformation magic grey tried to get
her stepsisters to accept her by
transforming her appearance to look like
them however her stepsisters were
outraged they saw this as a form of
mockery and they demanded that grey
change her appearance back to normal
immediately but because grey still
hadn't perfected her transformation
magic she wasn't able to turn back right
away so she was forced to run away from
her sisters she ended up running out of
the house and out into the woods but in
the woods grey came across a band of
robbers and when they saw her fancy
clothes they decided to rob her and
potentially do even worse things to her
thankfully goshen Marie showed up in the
nick of time and gauche was able to use
his mirror magic to take out the robbers
gray thanked goes for rescuing her but
gold said that he only did it because
that was what Marie wanted as you might
remember after goshen Marie lost their
parents and were ostracized by society
go stopped caring about anyone else
except for his baby sister he
made it his life's purpose to protect
Murray because the two of them had no
one else in the world except each other
and yet Ghosh did rescue gray and he
gave her some very good advice as well
ghost told her that if she's not fully
committed to running away then she
should just go back home because in this
world there are dangers lurking around
every corner and if she is committed to
running away then she also has to be
prepared to do everything with her own
two hands
without that staunch commitment and the
willingness to do whatever it takes
she will not be able to survive in this
cruel world gray took this advice to
heart she managed to survive and she
eventually joined the black bulls the
black bulls became her friends and her
true family and yet Ghosh doesn't seem
to even know that gray was the girl whom
he had rescued that night after all
because of her transformation magic and
trying to look like her sisters gray
looked completely different back when
she first met Ghosh and Marie but gray
knows that it was ghost who saved her
and she feels indebted to him she wants
to return to favour by saving him now
that he is in his hour of need
gray then says that despite her shyness
and reluctance to have anyone looking at
her true appearance she wants gauche to
look at her more and she blushes like
crazy while saying it I think that we
all know what that means in the world of
anime wink-wink nudge-nudge gray then
proceeds to unlock a new spell which
allows her to magically close Ghosh's
massive wound and save his life in my
previous black lore video I said that
Ghosh will most likely die unless there
is a massive [ __ ] like gray suddenly
unlocking a new healing spell and that
is literally exactly what happened I
mean I do think that this is a bit of an
ass pull from a narrative perspective
but this is a shounen series and after
what we saw with Julius vs poetry and
universes Zenon nothing surprises me
anymore
don't get me wrong I do like the fact
that we got grace back story and her
apparent secret crush on go
is pretty cute I especially like the
irony of someone like gray who is
traumatized about her appearance and
insecure about other people looking at
her having a crush on someone who uses
mirror magic of all things but even
though I liked all of this stuff Gosha
survival is still an [ __ ] in my
opinion but even though I can readily
admit that I'm still glad the ghost
didn't die and I'm looking forward to
seeing whether his relationship with
grey will develop and whether he will
chill out with all the little sister
stuff also I'm sure there will be some
explanation for why transformation magic
was able to heal Ghosh
maybe Grey's magic evolved to transform
the bodies of other people as opposed to
just her own whatever it is I'm sure
that it will make sense from the
perspective of the magic in the black
clover world Vanessa is shocked to see
the incredible effects of Gray's new
spell and Dante is surprised too
dante has seemingly managed to take care
of hasta pretty easily and Austin's
motionless body drops to the ground his
new black hosta form dissipating Dante
says that this is fantastic because he
didn't realize that grey was also an
arcane stage mage and he proceeds to ask
both Vanessa and grey to be his women he
got a love Dante I've been calling him
demon king Dante because of his demon
powers and kingly crown but maybe I
should start calling him harem King
Dante from now on yes he is an evil
villain but man is he ever a man of
culture unfortunately before Dante can
get a chance to Netflix and chill with
gran Vanessa a massive slash of dark
magic cuts through the ground between
Dante and the ladies the next page
reveals that Yami and Finn Rahl have
finally arrived and Yami like the jacked
badass that he is tells Dante that no
one messes with his people and that is
how the chapter ends having just set up
an absolutely epic magical showdown
between the one and only ami and the
harem King Dante both men are
overpowered mages and true WOM and
respecters so I can't wait to see them
Duke it out on the battlefield I've been
saying for the last few weeks that
castas new form won't be strong enough
to defeat dante but it might just be
strong enough to keep Dante busy long
enough for Yami to return and thankfully
that is exactly what happened however by
the looks of it hasta has been
thoroughly defeated by Dante and it
doesn't seem like hasta will be back on
the battlefield anytime soon
this means that Yami will have to take
Dante on man to man and he likely won't
be able to count on Asta's help at least
not for a little while I think that
hasta will need some time to recover
before he can fight again dark magic
versus demon gravity magic is going to
be an absolutely legendary Clash of
Kings I can't wait to see what happens
and overall I did really enjoy this
chapter I do think that the gauche
healing spell was a bit of an [ __ ]
but that's just the way black clover
works if Julius could time-travel
resurrect himself and if million von
gents could heal like half of the Golden
Dawn squad out of nowhere after the
Xenon fight then it shouldn't surprise
us that gold could end up being healed
even though he was clearly fatally
injured with that said I am glad that
ghosts arrived because I love all the
black bulls as a squad and I don't want
to lose any of them I also would have
felt so bad for poor little Marie if her
brother had died that child has been
through enough let me know what you guys
think are you okay with the gauche
recovery and what do you think of Gray's
backstory and what about Gray's magic
how was she able to unlock this new
spell also is a gray ex go ship about to
set sail I can definitely ship it
especially with the delicious irony of
having someone who is insecure about
being looked at falling in love with
someone who uses a mirror magic not
gonna lie that was pretty gamer of
tabata also do you think that Yami is
going to be able to hold his own against
Dante or is Dante just too strong we
know that Yami is extremely tough and
his dark magic is unique unlike other
magic from this world
Yami's dark magic had a significant
effect on zag red so maybe this will
turn out to be an important asset in the
fight against Dante as well I predict
that Yami is definitely going to need
some help although I'm not sure how soon
hasta will be able to recover
we'll have to wait and see I've been
saying this for a while but black clover
is so freakin interesting right now and
this war arc is absolutely epic let me
know if you agree down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video you want
to see more black clover content right
here on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications and
also if you're not new you've been
watching us for awhile but you still
haven't subscribed please consider
subscribing it really does help me feel
free to check me out on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime uproar I want to give
a huge thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thanks to baby R a
disciple of Lord we go himself and I
can't forget all are the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including Inc Rada
al Olin Adam the world stealers the
school bus Tyson query know a quiet
respect but a heffa and chris low-key
finally big thanks to all of our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing about a fan Jason
Wilson Odin Anatoly Cassatt's ki alpha
do on hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP fitty dolla beat Ted
no Ted Salter Joe Stanton very gucci
jessica calif on alicia actor levi
emperor otaku and JC c waka if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our page
and exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]